we're fighting a virus we're also
fighting emotions on an individual level
on a collective level and acknowledge
that it's hard
and i'm scared i'm scared hey by the way
i'm scared
right i'm fighting for my mother i'm
frightened for my brother
right how is your brother he's good look
first of all he's
50 years old then he's like superman
right so right but
how is he broadcasting through this it's
not i guess he didn't get hit that heavy
right
no he got hit heavy you want to talk
about guts i don't want to say this to
him
the day he was diagnosed
he went on air that night
jesus from his basement
i know it's crazy that's guts
because when you get this i don't care
how tough you are
there's a part of you that says maybe
i'm the one i know it's only one in a
hundred but maybe i'm the one
in a hundred who is going to be the
young person who dies
you want to talk about that moment that
tells us who we are
that day he showed me something i'll
tell you the truth
i'll tell you something with you and
your brother i mean it's turned into a
thing you know like even my psychiatrist
said to me
god don't you love when governor cuomo
and his brother talk
it's just so delightful
no no no don't do do it put the
microphone back on don't be like that
and don't hold it in your hand because
the hand swallows up the take that
picture you can't get any sound out of
it
hey put it back up the picture down geez
you guys got a little chemistry going
it's
you make it look good yeah it is it is
sweet
it is really sweet and it's also 100
genuine it's not and i don't even have
an alternative you know that is how i
relate to him period and that's how i
feel it's just a pure genuine authentic
and he's a
funny guy and we do get into this rhythm
from you know we go right back to
childhood